[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
el pasado 23 de junio la comisión de la
verdad de colombia realizó un encuentro
entre antiguos miembros de la guerrilla
de las farc y varias de sus víctimas de
secuestro quienes estuvieron en
cautiverio durante meses o años en las
selvas colombianas una de las personas
que habló fue ingrid betancourt ella fue
candidata presidencial cuando las farc
la secuestrada estuvo en cautiverio
durante más de seis años
ingrid bienvenida a france 24 min
gracias es un placer estar con ustedes
gracias una pregunta ingrid 10 una de
las exigencias más recurrentes de las
víctimas es verdad petición de perdón y
reparación usted cree que la
implementación del acuerdo de paz se
construye en ese sentido sí claro ha
construido bastante la verdad se está
reconstruyendo es decir yo creo que ese
es un proceso que se está dando a través
de la comisión de la verdad el perdón
bueno ellos han pedido perdón y nosotros
ya los perdonamos las víctimas hemos
hecho ese ejercicio que es un ejercicio
muy individual pero
cada uno de nosotros lo ha hecho
conciencia falta las reparaciones y yo
creo que ese es un espacio en el cual
colombia todavía no está claro no hay un
esquema ya elaborado así que a pesar de
eso pues si pienso que hemos avanzado
usted en el encuentro de la comisión de
la verdad dijo que esperaba escuchar a
los ex miembros de las farc hablar desde
el corazón y no desde la política pero
finalmente como cree que ellos hablaron
no ellos están presos de su ideología yo
creo que ellos todavía no han aterrizado
en el posconflicto
esa es la la valoración que yo hago yo
pienso que tiene una dificultad real a
hablar desde el corazón yo creo que la
guerra los marcó lo lees lees endureció
sus sensibilidades no son capaces de
demostrar emociones y yo pienso que en
ese sentido uno uno siente una
diferencia en el camino recorrido por
las víctimas que es un camino donde ha
habido mucho perdón donde ha habido
mucha generosidad donde
mucho afán de aportarle a colombia para
que colombia salga de la guerra de la
violencia del odio y la actitud bastante
rígida de los comandantes de las farc o
ex comandantes de las farc en que uno ve
que ellos están metidos en una lógica
electoral donde cuando hablan hablan de
política cuando son escenarios de
reconciliación de reencuentro del alma
todavía no han llegado ya
y en qué tipo de gestos ve usted que
ellos todavía están presos de sus
ideologías políticas yo creo que en la
ausencia de gestos es decir en el
encuentro de ayer en la comisión de la
verdad lo que puso de presente fue
precisamente esa ausencia de gestos la
imposibilidad por ejemplo para losada de
pedir perdón y ahora hemos perdonado
llegamos nosotros las víctimas
habiendo perdonado sin odio con ganas de
escucharlos de huir los de
reencontrarnos con un ser humano y él no
fue capaz de salir de la defensiva de
una actitud poquito soberbia de decir yo
no me va a prestar en un escenario
público a hacer una declaración que no
siento pues es precisamente el punto es
que no siente es que no la sintió no no
no pudo pedir perdón en el caso de
timochenko yo siento que había en él una
real
el compromiso de expresar su voluntad de
pedir perdón de hacer una constricción
pero eso es muy intelectual es decir
están todavía con como paralizados por
la imposibilidad de perder la faz ellos
tienen que aceptar perder la faz
reconocer el crimen que se cometió es
ante todo poder llorar con nosotros
poder compartir nuestras pesadillas
poder cuestionarse sobre lo que ellos
vivieron los momentos en que hubieran
podido cambiar las cosas para nosotros
hubieran podido liberar al papá de
andrés felipe lópez un niño de 7 años
que estaba
suplicando que soltaran a su papá porque
se estaba muriendo de cáncer
el niño se murió el papá trató de
escapar las farc lo ejecutaron y tenemos
la historia de esa deshumanización con
dos decisiones que tomaron los
comandantes que acabaron con la
credibilidad de las farc es decir yo
creo que si hoy ellos quieren
ser colombianos entrar a la familia
colombiana la tienen que hacer no
solamente con la voluntad política no
solamente con sus ideologías sino como
seres humanos como colombianos que
tienen que deshacerse de toda esa coraza
de guerreros que tienen bueno usted
habla de carlos antonio lozada que fue
el alias que tuvo julián gallo durante
el conflicto armado colombiano y también
se refirió a timochenko que es el alias
de el antiguo jefe de las farc rodrigo
londoño ellos estuvieron en el evento y
como usted lo dice ambos tuvieron un
discurso diferente sin embargo también
se marcó un discurso frente a los mandos
medios y las víctimas dijeron que el
lenguaje es una de las armas que siguen
haciendo daño a quienes padecieron el
secuestro usted percibió algún cambio de
lenguaje entre los antiguos mandos
medios de las farc y los ex comandantes
como rodrigo londoño hijo jan gallo y
como percibió estas palabras yo creo que
hay digamos yo pienso que hay una
rigidez por parte del cuerpo
de lo que es hoy comunes es decir hay
una rigidez ideológica y como común en
doctrina miento si se quiere yo creo que
ellos pueden tener miedo de decir cosas
que los involucre o los
digamos les produzca unas condenas más
altas frente al tribunal de la paz no sé
no sé cuáles pueden ser sus miedos pero
pero si siento que tienen bloqueos ahora
también sentí en ese en ese evento que
en algunos momentos uno sentía por parte
de mandos medios como
como una voluntad de reflexionar en lo
que había pasado en algún momento creo
que emilio dice emiro dice
cuando yo me fui pal monte mataron a mi
hermano y mi mamá se enloqueció perdió
la cabeza
eso es uno lo entiende yo como víctima
no entiendo por qué mi mamá perdió la
cabeza cuando me secuestraron
pero yo no veo en ellos la capacidad de
decir a mí me sucedió esto por lo tanto
yo entiendo lo que sucedió lo que le
sucedió a usted
otro dice
yo me he puesto a pensar yo cómo hubiera
reaccionado hacia mí me secuestran yo
como hubiera vivido años dentro de una
jaula yo como viera
eso ya es un avance en eso ya siente uno
que por lo menos se está preguntando el
mismo cómo hubiera vivido la situación
que nos hicieron vivir pero también hay
casos que son que le darán a uno
pensando por ejemplo uno de ellos dice
cuando yo veía esas imágenes
y creo que fue pastor alape que dijo yo
veía esas imágenes
me promocionaba mirando que estaban
detrás de sus alambradas de púas
fueron 15 años
quince años en que hubieran podido
debatir esa manera de crear esos campos
de concentración en que hubieran puedes
decir bueno de ahora en adelante no se
va a hacer pero la verdad real es que lo
que yo viví es que ellos filmaban esos
campos de concentración y los hacían
públicos se la entregan a la prensa
colombiana para que nuestras familias
vieran para que el dolor de de nuestras
familias fuera utilizado para poder
forzar las estrategias políticas y
militares que ellos tenían es decir
ellos nos usaron a nosotros yo hubiera
querido que en ese encuentro de ayer
ellos se hubieran dicho
nosotros hicimos esto qué horror lo que
hicimos como nos duele yo pienso en eso
y no puedo estar tranquilo y tengo
pesadillas y no sea algo
humano yo no vi ninguna humanidad y eso
es lo que me preocupa ahora
esto es un proceso
y ellos espero que lo que pasó ayer los
ayude a reflexionar porque si ellos
logran pasar esa especie como de de
frialdad y pueden conectarse con el
sentimiento de los colombianos entonces
vamos a poder decir que estamos saliendo
del horror de la guerra y que estamos
caminando hacia la paz
usted dice que en el encuentro de la
comisión de la verdad no vio humanidad
por parte de los antiguos miembros de
las farc y sigue un evento más o menos
similar y es que la jurisdicción
especial para la paz es que es el
mecanismo de justicia transicional de
colombia también creado por el acuerdo
de paz ya imputó a los 8 antiguos
comandantes del secretariado de las farc
que era la cúpula militar y política de
esta guerrilla lo que sigue ahora es una
audiencia de reconocimiento en el que
esos antiguos comandantes se encontrarán
con las víctimas usted estaría dispuesta
otra vez a participar en un evento
similar bueno a mí no me han participado
de esa audiencia no sé cuál sea la
expectativa de la gente ni cómo vayan a
manejar esa situación obviamente es un
espacio jurídico no es un espacio humano
es decir nosotros con el padre de ruth
estamos realmente enmarcados en un
espacio de encuentros de humanidades que
no se dio fue una oportunidad perdida
obviamente si se da algo en la red
y se vuelve a estar en un espacio
con ellos físicamente cercanos y yo eso
no podría darse no estaría en contra de
que se podría si fuera el caso y que me
invitaran podría considerarlo
sería otra oportunidad para ellos de
andar el camino hay que mirar y yo creo
que parte d
es decir de ser íntegros y honestos con
la paz es no encasillarnos y no meter al
otro en un no congelarlo
en juzgarlo por lo tanto qué bueno que
esa sea una oportunidad que ellos que
ellos tengan para poder de pronto
sintonizarse humanamente con el país
no sé si cede no sé si ellos estén
listos psicológicamente para hacer ese
tránsito
[Música]
pero bueno qué bueno que haya su
oportunidad y gritos muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 mil
veces
y esto fue la entrevista gracias por
estar con nosotros y para más
información continúen con france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]